let's get into hatred mail for the week
hatred mail of course when a
professional voice-over artist reads the
hate mail that I get quick reminder hey
we'd probably poison our entire family
if Trump told us to but remember it's
not a cult Patriot man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom all right
and here is this week's hatred mail
needing no introduction whatsoever daily
news kuck boy david pakman still
clueless david shill for The Wall Street
stock market hack man poor David doesn't
get it that it doesn't matter Trump will
win Trump will win Trump will win and
then you will cry cry cry the greatest
stock market of our time and yes I am
invested not some backwater hillbilly is
as you think of is trumpets David's hair
is also insane this is funny because
I've said from the beginning I wouldn't
be surprised at all if Donald Trump is
the winner of the November 20 2011 I
don't know why Trump ist's like to
pretend that it would come as some great
shock to me if Donald Trump was
reelected I've been saying for a while I
believe the most likely single outcome
is Trump re-elected followed by you know
a slice that says this Democratic
candidate is the president a slice that
says this other Democratic candidate is
the president I would not be shocked and
so anybody writing to me saying I'm
gonna be the one crying crying crying in
shock on November 4th uh the day after
the election I have been saying for a
while that that is the scenario that I
am scared of but believe is not an
unlikely one so maybe you've got this
show confused with a different one
remember that you can use the coupon
code hey tree at forty h80
RI o T for zero to get 40% off a
membership at join pakman.com and when
you use that code
the hatreds become irate because they
are unable to dissuade people from
supporting independent media